bonjour les mortels je suis Alex et
bienvenue dans l'antre des ténèbres
Halloween saint-vita table alors ils
sont chauds parce que moi
[Musique]
vous couperez la moustache une fois que
vous aurez plus besoin de faire peur
ça fait partie de l'ambiance
et en plus de ça c'est bon enfant merci
Philippe Martinez d'être venu en
Télématin merci à vous merci beaucoup à
vous deux gardez la moustache ça vous va
très bien Philippe Martinez
[Applaudissements]
c'est la hutte finale dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône c'est l'affluence aux
pompes plusieurs stations services
affichent déjà des ruptures de stock
station sur Gardanne fermée juste à côté
de chez moi et juste ici quoi je viens
d'en trouver c'est juste une prévoyance
objectif le pH du Boulou ajouté 200 à
bloquer ce passage stratégique à la
frontière franco-espagnole depuis 7h30
ce matin résultat des kilomètres de
bouchons et des tensions avec les
automobilistes
dans la merde c'est ça que je vous dis
moi je t'adore pour lutter Bernard on va
pas se plaindre après quand il y en a
plus ben c'est comme les bonbons il y en
a plusieurs n'a plus et on roulera pas
et puis voilà quoi
des manifestants très motivés au
discours déjà très bien rodé
aujourd'hui on se mobilise parce que
c'est la journée de la jeunesse dans la
continuité de la Grave revenu type qui
se fait en ce moment dans les transports
et les raffineries on va pousser on va
pousser pour bloquer le pays on a tout
essayé avec le gouvernement et ça marche
pas
à midi tapante
[Musique]
qui voudraient rentrer
et vous venez vous faites chier le monde
c'est une minorité là qui souhaitent
rentrer dans le lycée mais il faut
savoir que nous on milite justement pour
le reste de la France non milite pour la
France pour un pays au niveau national
on surveille les voitures quand même
c'est des mineurs qui sont en train de
faire des Corées enfin on sait pas trop
pourquoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'ingrédient qui donne toute la force à
la potion c'est quoi la solidarité vous
faites comment pour tenir je fais 3h du
matin
il est toujours en poste non il est mort
le bras d'honneur d'Éric Dupont-Moretti
l'image vient d'être dévoilée par Paris
Match on y découvre le garde des sceaux
esquisser ce geste insultant à
l'attention du député LR Olivier Marleix
non pas un mais deux mais trois bras
d'honneur plutôt timides dans leur
réalisation vous pouvez le constater
vous le saviez vous commentez bras
d'honneur en langue des signes avant
hier et bien maintenant vous saurez en
plus il y a moyen de mnémotechnique
super simple pour s'en rappeler regardez
ça se dit comme ça on doit pas faire de
bras d'honneur dans l'hémicycle
[Rires]
dans les commentaires beaucoup sont
choqués de voir un ministre se comporter
ainsi des gestes obscènes et mal
maîtrisés ironise cette internaute après
le taux et le Garde des Sceaux avait été
rappelé à l'ordre par Elisabeth borne et
c'était excusée Emmanuel Macron a décoré
de la Légion d'Honneur cette semaine les
ex-ministre de la santé Agnès Buzin et
de la justice Nicole Belloubet qu'on
s'en fout au pas Kevin on s'en fout pas
[Musique]
les copains d'abord
Bruno bah on s'en fout pas parce que moi
j'ai la Légion d'Honneur est-ce que je
la mérite ou pas je sais pas mais c'est
à titre civile
c'est pour répondre à ceux qui vont
aller sur les réseaux sociaux dire voilà
bon moi je l'ai eu grâce à ma carrière
de policiers aurait des autres bref j'ai
réussi enfin à être entendu en juillet
dernier Ophélie appelle le 17 son
ex-conjoint la menace de la tuer devant
sa porte mais dès les premiers mots
l'homme au bout du fil ne prend pas
l'appel au sérieux et va jusqu'à
insulter la jeune femme quand il m'a
raccroché au nez je me suis dit mais
qu'est-ce que je fais là la police il
m'aide pas qui va m'aider une femme qui
meurt tous les deux jours
oui je vous l'apprends visiblement à
votre place honnêtement je serai pas
comme ça tout détendu en train de sortir
un livre mais franchement je trouve ça
juste honteux
au bas de chez elle il la roue de coup
devant sa fille de 12 ans pour moi je me
suis fait agresser deux fois une fois le
31 une fois le premier ce genre de
personne peut pas être policier c'est
des criminels pour moi ils sont même
niveau que les agresseurs c'est
exactement pareil le policier et comme
de 8 mois de prison avec sursis et d'une
interdiction d'exercer son métier
pendant 18 mois une peine ferme mais
juste pour l'avocate d'Ophélie Pauline
Rongier
arrête de me dire des choses comme ça
avant non non il y a pas de vous rester
là là vous pouvez jeter je vous demande
de rester à moi que je découvre les
violences sexuelles
mais tu ne coule fusil l'assemblée a
donc refusé cette évolution de la loi on
peut donc toujours frapper sa femme et
représenter les Français au Parlement
néanmoins le débat sur le sujet n'est
peut-être pas fini puisque hier la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale il y
a le Braun pivée a proposé que soit
inscrit dans la Constitution
l'obligation d'avoir un casier
judiciaire vierge pour se présenter à
une élection c'est trop facile de faire
ce que vous êtes en train de faire vous
osez le dire dans les yeux que je
connais pas les violences que je
connaissent les bras
est terminé